When I arrived in the UK, I was surprised to see how international is this community,...
...and literally people are coming from all over the world.
Not only students, but also the staff.
That is actually a very strong message that is very rare internationally.
The fact that you have a culture that is open enough...
...actually, to allow other people to come in from different countries,...
...if they deserve it, to take key jobs.
In the UK, you have a very strong concept of meritocracy.
One of the aspects of the UK I really like is having a foot in the past and a foot in the future.
This is one of the events of the Royal Society to celebrate the 350th anniversary of the Royal Society.
What I think is fantastic is the idea that such a great institution that goes past centuries is not just a fossil.
It's still an institution and it's inspiring us to do great science today.
I was awarded a university research fellowship by the Royal Society.
Of course, if I come here and I look at all these beautiful portraits of scientists like Newton, Boyle,...
...then I feel a lot of pressure.
You have all the past talking to you...
...to sort of support you and encourage you to do a brighter future.
Are there any planets with other Royal Society looking back at us and seeing us as alien?
I really think that simple life, in terms of bacteria microorganisms,...
...is probably very common out there.
Maybe civilization, it's something a little bit more difficult to form.
We shall see what this theorem will tell us.